las vegas is coming together comes
together every year to help raise
awareness and funds
for the fight against pancreatic cancer
and here's how you can help
nikki company welcome to the show oh
thank you for having me
you are a nurse practitioner here to
teach us about pancreatic cancer and i
know there's a special event
coming up soon but first let's just get
into the numbers of pancreatic cancer
just from 2020
sure so in
2020 an estimated 57 000 americans were
diagnosed
um with pancreatic cancer and if you do
the math that comes
out to about 158 every day
and actually the numbers for 2021
are projected that 60 430 people
will be diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
and the projected number of people dying
from this disease is in 2021
is 48 220. what are the symptoms of
pancreatic cancer exactly
significant unexplained weight loss
frequent pain in the mid abdomen or
lower back
digestive problems
skin turning yellow abdominal bloating
or merely
change in bathroom habits can be um
a symptom so it's really important if
people are experiencing
any of these symptoms that they contact
their health care provider right away
and get a workup
absolutely and when they do that and if
they do have pancreatic cancer what does
the treatment look like
the treatment depends on the stage of
the disease
and the patient's general health
condition
they could get standard treatments or
take place
take part in clinical trials and
standard treatments
include surgery chemotherapy and
radiation
and what more we could do is continue to
raise awareness right
absolutely i understand that las vegas
does a really great job at that and we
have a special event coming up
we do we have purple stride las vegas
2021
coming up it's presented by optincare
cancer care
and that is coming up on saturday march
20th
and it's from wherever you are at one
time we would have the event at town
square
but with the pandemic and coveted 19
um the concept is stride your own way
so you whether you walk run bike ride
um boat whatever
the purple stride events are among the
largest sources of funding for the
pancreatic cancer
action network we want to thank
southwest medical for being one of our
community pride partners